one of my favorite bands one of so many
people love Duran Durant I've seen them
in concert I remember I met Simon Lebon
and I was just like hey I'm a big fan
he's like oh great he's very it's kind
of cold I'm sure you don't know him as
that or do you well the thing is about
being the lead singer of a band everyone
wants you you know even though John is
there and Nick is there and Roger is
there the Press tend to not know about
them you talk to Simon yeah and then
Simon said H we're going out sailing
tomorrow do you want to come no he asked
you to go sailing did you go oh
absolutely Chris and I were on the boat
and I I had to hold my back myself back
cuz I wanted to ask him to sing Rio
while we're on the boat CU that was the
video the music video absolutely but he
did wear the striped t-shirt Jesus man
that's a dream that's like to me if I
was on a boat with Duran Duran I think
life had you know that was it